[Music]
so
what's up guys it's amanda cerny and
welcome to tea time
this is where i play tennis with
different celebrities influencers
friends and family you name it
and we have a q a session while playing
and how we play
is that we have five rounds and whoever
wins three
out of the five rounds wins the whole
game and there's a very special prize
today i am playing with ricegum
what are we doing today at mana cerney
we're playing tennis and we have a lot
to catch up on so i have some questions
for you
what type of questions you'll see a lot
of people ask me on twitter
it's questions from the people and also
have you played tennis before
no honestly i haven't but i'm really
good with balls in my hand and the
racket stuff so
it should be a good game you know what
i'm saying okay let's get started
so rice heads or tails tails tails
tails damn
all right you pick who serves first me
or you you go first ladies first
ladies first you know what i'm saying i
don't mind if i do
all right first love servant love love
all
first question is
who do you think is going to win the
fight uh logan or ksi
oh [ __ ] uh well they're both athletic
and i'm friends with both of them but i
really
i think oh it's no
dude so i can't do this you know like
doing two things at once no
i think ksi might take it you know
it's gonna be a good fight though you
know i mean ksi got the experience but
logan got the size on him you know what
i'm saying so
who whoever wants it more i think
uh i think logan's gonna win
well i think his
[Applause]
almost got it almost got it you know
what i'm saying
why did you pick tennis what the heck
it's such a random sport
because i suck at it and i need to learn
to be better okay what is
one feature you don't like about
yourself
about me yeah one feature um
well i have a lot of scars but it's not
that i don't like it
yeah it's just like memories of me
eating [ __ ] you know okay okay okay
yeah like the one on my knee for
instance oh
i don't like remembering that because
it was a painful fall and i'm so clumsy
i was literally just running
in like beverly hills and i tripped and
you know the roads are like
gnarly gnarly and it took like a chunk
out of my knee
oh yeah and i was running down the
street with my leg like gushing blood
and everything
[Applause]
good times why did you choose the name
rice gum
well i was really bored and i like rice
and i like rice and i like gum you know
originally it was like a gamer name
thing you know what i'm saying and then
yeah you know just over the years i just
stuck with it but um
[ __ ] i'm glad i picked the name why is
your name amanda cerny huh
my mom you know oh okay okay okay
uh why did you move out of the house
oh i see that question so i made a video
but it was just
come on man no it was just clickbait i
didn't move
i still live with alicia violet and you
know face bang summer all that it was
just clickbait you know it's youtube
you you need a good clickbait on this
video okay you need a good one
because i suck at just clicking i'm
actually sweating oh my
god it's good we're on the first round
so
all right so this isn't me off again
i'm asked you a question all right yeah
and it's not me asking like it's from
twitter it's me asking
it's not me it's from twitter here we go
have you
ever kissed a girl yeah
i liked it and she just scored on me man
that just you empowered me have you
ever kissed a boy kissed a boy
yeah well well there was this one time
but i didn't know he was a boy i'm just
kidding
but there's nothing wrong with it you
know i'm saying i just personally never
have
so defensive
oh um well that was out
on me so she got the point man he's an
honest player good sport
that's what i do all right this is game
point
so question would be
how do you like living in la i like it
it's hot it's real hot i'm sweating
right now
but it makes work easier like how we
collaborated
like it was that easy you know what i'm
saying that's true that's why a lot of
people moved out here too
what's your favorite sneaker that you
own
i like bare feet because it's just so
much more comfortable
what's your favorite spot to visit my
favorite spot to visit
yeah my bed i really like to sleep at
night and get like
eight to 12 hours of sleep every night
damn it i think i just won
no i'm pretty sure
damn it sorry you have four more chances
whoever gets to three
i'm serving now so yep it's about to get
ugly
all right listen who is the last person
you texted
um i think it was oscar the camera guy
because he showed up at the wrong
location come on camera guy you can't be
doing that man
all right guys i need to win at least
one it's my first time playing tennis
though wait do i stand over here or here
this side and then this box we haven't
really been doing it but
you ready yeah close enough
um so for you no
so question for you is who's your
favorite
friend who's my favorite friend huh yep
honestly i think it's you amanda because
because you're the one that invites me
to go out and play tennis
if you did hit me up i'd be in my room
not being active you know what i mean
like
i'm trying to get in shape so let's go
dude it does twice right
let's go hello hello hello
he's trying to flatter me and then sneak
in a win
what is one thing you can't live without
water dude water really got no calories
man i [ __ ] love it man
you can only live how many days without
water not that many
30 y'all what's your favorite color
uh black you know i mean it's a hot day
but i still wore black i don't care if
it's attracting heat
and and i'm sweating from three
different angles i love
the color black
oh it's in it was it it was it was right
here
damn you gotta win this one are you
currently dating anybody
i am currently in a relationship with
the money with the bread
that's all i think about is money i'm
just kidding no i'm single
and uh i'm just really single man and
lonely man so if you're single hit him
are you single hit me up you know what
i'm saying
she's available um so was that
in i don't know i wasn't paying
attention
we'll just redo that one we won't give a
point to anybody on that
so it's still game point for me if i get
this i win this round
yeah yeah yeah okay question where is
the furthest place you ever
travel to oh [ __ ]
no no i went over it's fine
i won oh it's two no it's okay
i can still come back you can you have
to win these last three rounds
i got it don't worry about it i got it i
got it
for this place i've traveled to i think
was
dubai oh i went to dubai with blah blah
blah blah blah blah
oh thank you thank you thank
thank you oh he said you're welcome he
he said you had to say it like ten times
yeah i went with batch one time word and
it was so random but it was
it's beautiful king bash is my boy love
him
king bash is a boy love all
literally how do you feel that king bash
likes me more than you oh [ __ ]
oh oh
did i go away no i don't know how we're
playing
technically no technically no darn it
man
i'll give it to you though yes yes let's
go
do you think you're gonna live in la for
the rest of your life oh
i really don't think so because i plan
on being like a hundred years old
and there's no way i could be here for
80 more years come on
no yeah and there's no way the rest of
my life no way i'm gonna have houses all
over the world
you know say i'm a house i'm gonna have
a house in europe house in vegas
house in hawaii you know i mean so i'm
gonna be all over the place goals i like
it
can i stay in one of your houses around
the world i mean
if you know i mean if that ever happens
you know i mean a hundred percent
you could have a room oh come on
dude you've been practicing man i
haven't even played
boxers or briefs no dude i don't wear
underwear
but if if i had the pick probably brief
let's go to the ballpark let's go now
apparently briefs honestly briefs
briefs yeah do you have any balls
oh yeah she said
that's really bad if she says that do
you have any balls
i indeed do i do
okay like i'm just really curious
because i don't know
yeah oh no yes
40 30. now but like
i've been questioning this my whole
entire life and no one has ever told me
but like
do girls fart oh yeah oh they do yeah
especially
there's these one vegan burgers if you
eat them
i swear that'll be our next video you'll
be so
gassy i've been told that they don't but
now i know yeah they lied to you i mean
you
you live with girls right does summer
still live with you
well about that no
do i care i can't [ __ ] won the whole
game okay yo you gotta pick something
you know it's either
tennis or q a you know what i mean two
things you can't do at the same time i'm
a woman
i can't focus i can't fight multi-task
man it was a good game come here come
here
come here answer the last question and
come here
give me a hug it was a good game you're
still a winner in my book
just stay right here you're still a
winner
i love you so much and we haven't seen
each other in so long
i just wanted to give you a special gift
from the bottom of my heart oh what is
it
is this some jewelry like some like a
watch or something
it's real nice that's all you need it's
real nice so
step over here here it is
because your name is rice
and you like rice
thank you lifetime supply of rice
i knew you'd love it and so it's not um
wow it's not like a commentary on
ethnicity or anything
because of your name oh yeah yeah yeah
of course of course and gum i ate a
piece earlier why would you eat a
it's mine why would you eat a pizza
enjoy thank you so much for today
thank you yeah thank you guys so much
for watching that was fun
i feel like i improved a little bit on
my tennis game maybe not so much because
i was playing with rice
uh yeah so
for next week let me know who you want
to see on tea time
with a cerney it could be rice again so
he has a chance of winning i mean you
did win
you got the rice and the gum want it in
my heart like subscribe turn on those
notifications and comments
[Music]
below
you